pues es un debate mucho más con mucha
más altura de miras que otros que
habíamos observado con anterioridad en
esta larga tramitación de un proceso que
ha tardado más de cuatro años en
convertirse en ley que fue ingresado al
congreso por el segundo mandato de la
presidenta michelle bachelet retomado de
urgencia en la última cuenta pública por
parte del presidente piñera que fue uno
de los muchos que cambió en su opinión a
la hora de aprobar el matrimonio a la
hora de favorecer el matrimonio
igualitario y que culmina hoy con una
votación mayoritaria tanto en senadores
donde se aprobó por 21 votos a favor 8
en contra y 3 abstenciones como en la
cámara de diputados donde recibió 82
votos a favor 21 en contra y 2
abstenciones como de más la gran mayoría
de los parlamentarios en chile- también
pensaban que era hora de que en el país
existiera un matrimonio que garantizará
la igualdad de derechos para las parejas
de todo tipo de condición sexual
patricia esta decisión es definitiva o
es apelable
esta es una decisión definitiva el
propio gobierno celebraba hoy y afirmaba
que se trata de uno de los días más
alegres en la historia de chile un día
histórico agradecía a aquellas personas
que movieron la barrera de lo que era
posible en referencia a los activistas
de los movimientos por las disidencias
sexuales en chile que llevan muchísimos
años batallando por esto cuando era
totalmente impensable que las fuerzas
conservadoras del país pudieran aprobar
un proyecto como el que hoy ya se
celebra en el congreso de forma
mayoritaria que se celebrará también
esta tarde en las calles a las 19 horas
el móvil este movimiento uno de los dos
que ha estado empujando fuertemente por
este matrimonio igualitario tiene
convocada una manifestación para
celebrar este día histórico en chile en
el que todas las personas pueden
disfrutar de los mismos derechos sin
importar su condición sexual patricias
de muchas gracias por esta ampliación
estamos pendientes de lo que ocurre en
las próximas horas en chile- y sobre
todo en santiago